this video was sponsored by Adam and Eve
use code legal for 50 off one item plus
free shipping in the US and Canada some
exclusions apply uh that means I'll
expect you to be at work and in court as
the She-Hulk no no no
absolutely not not going to happen this
is an employment lawyer's worst
nightmare
okay today we are looking at She-Hulk
now I really want to like this show but
so far from the little bit that I've
seen my expectations about legal realism
are pretty low but today let's look at
the first half of season one of Shield
the defendant used their Limitless
resources political and monetary for
financial gain at the expense of Public
Safety causing the deaths of innocent
people that's a word they did this
because they believed they would not be
held accountable that their power
shielded them from very real
consequences but today you the jury
can prove that's not the case all right
off to a strong start we can see already
Jen Walters has two degrees from UCLA
one for undergrad and one for law school
you know who also has two degrees from
UCLA you boy League legal now I can
neither confirm nor deny that I also
have incredible superpowers uh we'll
we'll find out later I ask you to look
only at the facts of this case you'll
see that my client was well within his
right to protect his business interest
these accidental deaths were an
unfortunate byproduct of an ambitious
expansion plan
did my client know lives would be
endangered
that is debatable
it depends on your definition of knowing
uh okay so this is a terrible closing
argument it's basically just a word
solid of legal Concepts thrown together
in a way that is not persuasive at all
and the craziest thing here is that this
is the defense which for some reason in
this alternate universe the defense
gives their closing argument in a
criminal case before the prosecution
that is not how this works uh the
prosecution has the burden of proof and
they always go first in terms of closing
arguments so it makes absolutely no
sense that Jen Walters has not given her
closing argument before the defense has
but that's uh pretty far down in terms
of legal inaccuracies at this point yeah
yeah so this chick pretty decent turned
into a Hulk like like a chick Hulk a
She-Hulk
exactly
okay so I really enjoyed the supposed
name of this lawyer bar the legalese uh
the thing is though despite this being a
Trope in lots of different TV shows in
my experience lawyers don't congregate
in like some nearby bar to the
courthouse after hours in my experience
lawyers tend to drink alone at home it's
actually kind of a problem substance
abuse is a real thing among lawyers we
didn't win the case oh yeah we did GLK
and H had it declared a mistrial okay uh
so a mistrial was declared that's not
crazy the standard for mistrial is that
the defendant uh cannot receive a fair
trial the chances of receiving a fair
trial are irreparably damaged uh the
thing is though when a mistrial is
declared
there's going to be a do-over they're
going to have another trial you don't
lose the case the defendant doesn't walk
free it's just that this particular Jury
has to be dismissed and you have to do
it all over again just the same since
you save the lives of the entire jury
today glknh argued that the jury was
then biased in your favor what was I
supposed to do like let them get hit in
the face within a desk and then they
have blunt force trauma and they're all
bleeding out all over the courtroom
before and no you did the right thing
but it unraveled our case it didn't it
didn't unravel their case and if
anything it would be more reason for her
to be Counsel on the next trial because
she's gotten all this publicity that Not
only was she a lawyer but she also saved
the lives of the jury so the idea that
her district attorney boss is upset is
preposterous Jen I'm sorry I have to let
you go this makes you a liability for
the diesel what okay all right
Preposterous that they would be upset
that they lost the case because of
mistrial which isn't losing case but
double or Tripoli so that they're firing
her because she transformed into
She-Hulk and saved the jury there's an
argument here that this is a violation
of the Ada the Americans with
Disabilities Act prohibits
discrimination against people with
disabilities in terms of employment and
the Civil Rights Act of 1964 prohibits
discrimination on the basis of race
color religion sex or national origin
and here she has a genetic abnormality
that makes her a superhero there are all
kinds of issues here and also
I mean this is a small thing but often
District Attorney's offices have unions
so there would be a whole grievance
procedure she's a government employee so
she receives all kinds of due process
protections the manner in which she was
fired impossible absolutely possible
ridiculous it's just a plot device to
get her to go somewhere else
oh hey Devin Nando here just wanted to
clear something up that plot Point makes
way more sense in the comic they're
taking it directly from there is a
similar moment where Jen is fired from
her Law Firm because after she saved the
jury the case gen 1 is deemed a mistrial
however there are two pretty big
differences that make the firing work in
the book better than it does in the show
One Jen is a mess she had a rough early
2000s but second more importantly
because Jen was an Avenger at the time
the court case in the book is not
interrupted by Titania trying to mess up
that Courthouse but Modoc the big evil
head in a floating chair trying to
freeze the entire planet so I think
Jen's boss has a stronger case here this
is not an isolated incident everyone on
the planet has been saved by She-Hulk so
you could say Jen has undo leverage over
every potential juror in every case and
therefore anyone arguing against Jen
could get a Mistry file on the basis
that Jen saved those jurors too
down for your job Miss Walters you laid
out a winning case against us before I
had it declared a mistrial of course
it's no easy feat against GLK h
uh so I would like you to come work for
us okay this is slightly less
unrealistic and frankly I think this
probably would happen in the wake of Jen
Walters becoming She-Hulk and saving the
entire jury and presumably having uh
above average legal skills because she
went to UCLA law I can absolutely see
that some Law Firm would reach out and
want to capitalize on that good
publicity so you know I think that's a
cool idea you got me fired now you want
to hire me to be head of new division
yes take some time I accept
but
I will only do it if I can hire my own
paralegal non-negotiable
I truly do not care who your paralegal
is
okay that's a great line
um would some senior partner care about
her hiring a paralegal absolutely not
whatsoever uh kind of a ridiculous
condition I would want to know how much
I was being paid uh I would want to know
if I was a capital or Equity partner in
the law firm I would want to know if I
get a percentage of the law firm's
um Revenue because you know unclear how
much actual lawyering she's going to be
able to do so if they want to capitalize
on her notoriety and there are lots of
Partners in law firms that don't
actually do much practicing they are
there to be rainmakers and and get
people to come in the door uh you know
she should get a percentage of the
profits of that law firm she has
negotiated none of these things you
would expect her to do so
um I am questioning her her business
skills if not her legal skills at this
point we just started a superhuman law
Division and I want you well the
She-Hulk to be the face of it oh yeah
okay so uh in a world where superheroes
are real I can absolutely see law firms
specializing in superhero law
um you know this particular YouTube
channel has covered a lot of the
implications of superheroes being
um shall we say uh legally controversial
and I can absolutely believe that there
would be a million different things that
not only superheroes would need to have
covered from a legal perspective but
also you know victims of superhero crime
or super villain crime and the aftermath
of superheroes saving the day but also
causing lots and lots of damage so
um yeah I think a superhero law division
is a really neat idea
um a little upset that they didn't call
me first about that though uh that means
I'll expect you to be at work and in
court as the She-Hulk right now
um
terrific
no no
no absolutely not not going to happen
this is an employment lawyer's worst
nightmare that uh some uh partner at the
firm some old white guy is demanding
that Jen Walters turn into She-Hulk uh
as a condition of her employment
absolutely not you know there are
places that can require you to dress in
a certain way Hooters is the classic
example that there is a sexual nature to
the restaurant and so they have been
allowed to require certain sexualized uh
uniforms and and things of that nature
read the sign prevart
a law firm doesn't have that purpose and
you can't have differing uh requirements
between men and women or a specific
person it's crazy especially given the
the rule 34 nature of She-Hulk in
general
um do not Google that
um yeah I mean this is not going to fly
now arguably the law firm would say
well we hired you because you have
notoriety uh as She-Hulk and and we want
She-Hulk to be the lawyer the thing is
everybody knows that her identity of Jen
Walters is synonymous with Shield so I
don't think they have a good argument Mr
Blonsky I was expecting Abomination
right you won't be saying much of him
about honestly I've completely
transformed myself
you know physically obviously but
Also spiritually okay I think this is a
really neat idea in the world of
superhero law you have a former super
villain who was captured uh put in jail
in a super max jail and served out his
time now query whether he actually would
get out of jail given that I think a lot
of his charges has been a long time
since I've seen the original Hulk movie
uh involve a lot of attempted murder
um so you know query whether he's
actually eligible for parole but the
thing is prisons
theoretically at least are not in the
habit of confining people for the rest
of their lives unless the crime itself
calls for them to be incarcerated for
their entire lives and it's entirely
possible that if all the charges were
related to property damage then okay he
served his time and he might be eligible
for parole and you can imagine in a
world of supervillainy that people would
be uneasy about a super villain being
released back into the rest of humanity
but the thing is that the prison
shouldn't be confining him forever and
this is a really interesting analogy to
real life we have people that did
something bad but the punishment doesn't
allow them to be confined for the rest
of their lives and they have to be
reintegrated eventually so this is a
really cool idea I like that they're
exploring this so far there have been no
statements made by Emil blonsky's
attorney after shocking footage leaked
showing the Abomination participating in
what appears to be an underground Fight
Club after having somehow escaped from
prison oh you understand that this
constitutes another crime and totally
destroys your chances at parole wow okay
so that's accurate if a prison inmate
decided to leave prison uh that would be
considered a separate crime though you
would have to criminally prosecute them
for that separate crime it wouldn't just
be up to the prison to say you escaped
from prison and we're tacking on you
know 10 years to your sentence I was
forced to leave my cell but I returned
of my own free will who forced you to
escape sorcerer's Supreme of the Mystic
Arts and his name is Wong just Wong okay
so I think what's gonna happen here is
that this is going to involve uh the
parole aspect of it you would imagine
that someone trying to get out of jail
uh to escape would uh reflect negatively
on a parole board hearing wow and here
Emil Blonsky is going to try to
ameliorate that by saying that he didn't
try to escape he was forced to escape by
Wong we do have a witness who is able to
clear Mr blonde's give any wrongdoing on
his part then we'll start with that then
well uh yes the the witness is prepared
to give a statement okay uh that is
completely ridiculous that the stakes
here are will Wong show up to this uh
Parole Board hearing I mean I imagine
what you would do is uh you would
probably want to have him testify in
person but for belts and suspenders you
would get a written declaration from
wrong Jennifer Walters would write it up
and Wong would sign it under uh penalty
of perjury and you would provide that to
the prison board so that nothing can go
wrong to make sure that the witness is
testifying that he forced uh Blonsky to
uh escape from prison this whole thing
about Wong well they show up or not is
totally contrived
thank you
here is a cease and desist cease and
desist
what cease and desist okay so I'm not
sure on what basis they can issue a
cease and desist to stop Donnie Blaze
from using this particular magic
um I mean look that has never stopped a
lawyer from writing a cease and desist
letter we see on the internet all sorts
of terrible lawyers write cease and
desists however
Dilly Dilly is the motto of our realm so
I guess in this sense this is just like
real life you have very dubious
circumstances in which to force someone
to stop doing something that you don't
want them to do and yet the lawyer is
writing a cease and desist letter to
threaten them we have filed a complaint
and a
random Shin against the defendant citing
unfair
unfair gross negligence I must say
counselor I am hard-pressed to believe
that a magic trick could constitute
gross negligence well okay yeah yeah uh
there is the question of whether a magic
trick can constitute gross negligence
but the the bigger issue here is that
Wong doesn't have standing to file suit
on the basis of negligence negligence is
a cause of action that uh requires you
to be injured by the act of negligence
so you know the young woman who was sent
to you know the demon realm she has a
cause of action for gross negligence
Wong does not he's a complete third
party now with respect to unfair
competition here Wong is not engaged in
Commerce uh he's not competing with
Donnie Blaze so that doesn't work either
also you would probably just turn this
over to the district attorney you have
someone walking around using what is
effectively a deadly weapon engaged in
all kinds of uh nefarious acts that's
probably something the district's
attorney should probably prosecute here
do you have any Witnesses who can
corroborate your claim
[Music]
yes we do your honor
[Music]
by the way lack of evidence is not the
problem here you can have tons and tons
of evidence but if you don't have a
cause of action that works in the
circumstances this case should be
dismissed and here this is exactly the
kind of case that should be dismissed on
a motion to dismiss I move to dismissed
you cannot copyright magic no there is
precedent according to Jen Walters
they're not filing a copyright suit
because you can't copyright magic it's
ah it's it's uh it's like someone pulled
out a legal dictionary flipped to a
random page through some words into the
script and then
you know set it in a courtroom my
client is obviously
no vading this ridiculous
defalcation
this is just a blatant attempt at
Nemo de
betroxy Pro una edem Kaza
no further questions
hello fellas good evening my lady before
I send my little friend here back to his
own Dimension I was wondering if you
would agree to the terms of our cease
and desist
fine okay we agree my office will be in
touch yeah okay so I mean
forming a contract uh while threatening
someone with a demon uh probably going
to constitute duress and whatever terms
they have agreed to uh is not going to
work basically this is the scleri
brothers joke from Ghostbusters 2. oh my
God I'm just in the order cases
I got a special delivery for a one
Jennifer Walters I recognize process
server when I see one ah right
I've got court documents filed by
Titania worldwide LLC okay I have to say
I really like this joke going in the
other direction and saying oh yeah I
totally recognize you're a processor but
just give me the papers so often we hear
about people trying to dodge service
there's no point you're going to be
served eventually it's just driving up
court costs she's suing you for misuse
of a trademark what trademark
she's suing me over the name She-Hulk
but that's my name now that she
trademarked it first right oh is that
how it works your honor yeah get at it
oh sorry thank you uh spoiler that is
not exactly how a trademark Works um
hopefully we'll we'll talk about that
more I am so sorry little child but the
line starts way back there I don't want
to cut okay so this is Titania who is
the super villain that burst into the
courtroom in episode one and nearly
killed half of the jury by throwing a
table at them
why is she not in jail she engaged in a
whole bunch of counts of attempted
murder what seems to be the issue you're
using my name to sell your trashy
products and you're suing me I'll get
over it Jennifer the name She-Hulk it's
mine so Titania here is using the mark
She-Hulk in Commerce with a bunch of
makeup products some of which appear to
have dubious efficacy
um so that makes sense to get a
trademark you have to generally speaking
use that Mark in Commerce which I think
tees up a really interesting idea in the
world of superhero law because you have
all these superheroes who are using a
name but they're not really using it in
Commerce they're using it to save people
you can imagine Superman he would never
try to commercially capitalize on the
term Superman whereas you can imagine a
whole bunch of other people would want
to capitalize on that so you can have a
situation where someone is using a name
here She-Hulk in an altruistic way but
someone else is is going to be first to
Market with some product in Commerce and
you can only get a trademark if you're
using something in Commerce you said you
didn't like the name She-Hulk anyways I
don't okay it is just what people have
decided to call me it's not who I am
okay so this adds a really interesting
wrinkle because trademark is not the end
of this discussion often people have
publicity rights in their name if you
have a certain amount of notoriety
people like Beyonce and Donald Trump
have uh trademarked and also created
other Protections in their own name
um to protect it from being diluted or
tarnished by someone else's use even as
a trademark GLK and H man Shield the
face of our superhuman law Division and
now we find ourselves in the middle of a
frivolous lawsuit
no one hires a firm that can't handle
its own messes I am going to fix this
sir
no you won't okay this is great
absolutely would happen if you had a a
partner in a Major law firm who was
being sued in a frivolous fashion it is
absolutely the case that the other
members of The Firm would just unleash
hell on the party that was engaging in
the frivolous lawsuit so it's it's
really funny that the senior partner is
is kind of like uh it's a bad look for
us to be sued and to to lose this kind
of thing so we're going to make sure
that you win since the first public
appearance of Jennifer Walters in her
Hulk form the public has unanimously
identified her with the name She Hulk in
fact the name She-Hulk had not even been
recorded in public discourse until that
debut okay by the way maybe a small
thing but I know TV shows portray the
practice of law as basically just like
two lawyers at a table arguing with the
judge that's not how a summary judgment
motion works the summary judgment motion
number one has to be noticed 75 days
ahead of time in California you have to
write a separate statement so you have
to compile every single relevant fact
put it into like an Excel spreadsheet
and show how there are no issues of
material fact that are in dispute and
then you have to have you know 30 pages
of law explaining why you're entitled to
win as a matter of law it's such a paper
intensive thing it would be hundreds and
hundreds of pages though I can see why a
TV show would not want to portray a real
motion for summary judgment because it's
super super boring the defendant is
exploiting Goodwill towards my client
and her better known cousin in order to
sell her non-fda approved sham products
we asked the court to grant our motion
for summary judgment and order our
requested remedies that makes no sense
they should have gone in for a temporary
restraining order at tro and eventually
a preliminary injunction a pi because
when you're dealing with these kinds of
Ip rights this is where you get
irreparable harm which is what is
required for a tro to restrain someone
temporarily you have to show irreparable
harm and when you're dealing with these
kind of Ip rights they're really
tarnishing the name and it's really hard
if not impossible to get that back they
are tarnishing the name She-Hulk by
associating it with shoddy beauty
products that would absolutely be the
sort of thing that would be stopped
pending a resolution in this case okay
first of all sham why is the client
talking the lawyer assuming this is oral
argument the lawyer is the only one who
can talk not the client sit down and
shut up that's no She-Hulk was not you
can sit down what my client is trying to
say is that Jennifer Walters was not
interested in the She-Hulk name until it
became associated with this incredibly
successful line of products
if we make
so
that this is a bona fide use in Commerce
she is not using it in Commerce and
therefore the the trademark is
successful now a couple things here
there's a difference between creating a
trademark and registering a trademark to
register a trademark you have to go to
the USPTO register it usually that takes
a couple of years assuming that there
aren't any objections and then it is
registered with the United States
government and then you can file suit
um generally speaking you have to
register to be able to file suit but
that's not how you create a trademark
you create a trademark by using it in
Commerce and just because it's not
registered doesn't mean you don't have
the trademark so there's an issue here
as to who was the first to use the mark
in Commerce that's who's going to win
not the person who was able to register
it first because I made a dating profile
as She-Hulk and went on several dates as
She-Hulk showing a clear pattern of
using the name every single one of those
dates is a corroborating witness this
is how I win this case
and I specifically remember her
referring to herself as She-Hulk okay so
I understand this as a plot device it's
fun that they're going to call in all
the ex-boyfriends and you know show that
she actually went by She-Hulk the thing
is that it's not probative of the issue
here she has to show use in Commerce
showing that you used the mark She-Hulk
in a dating profile is not using that in
Commerce that's not going to help them
so all of these Witnesses are completely
irrelevant they should object and never
be let into the courtroom now that being
said the best argument that she can make
here is that she was hired on the basis
of being She-Hulk and I want you well
the She-Hulk to be the face of she has
held herself out as She-Hulk the lawyer
so the evidence that they should use
here is calling her clients to the stand
that showing that they hired her on the
basis of the fact that she was She-Hulk
and she was portraying herself as Shield
motion for summary judgment is granted
Titania and her subsidiaries will cease
usage of the She-Hulk name effective
immediately it makes sense that Jennifer
Walters wins I wish they would have
dealt with the issue of a truly
altruistic superhero though Superman
Spider-Man
um Captain America you know they're not
going to be using their particular marks
or their names in Commerce so it would
have been more fun to deal with that
particular issue oh man then you've
gotta read Ultimate Spider-Man they did
a thing where Kingpin bought the
wrestling company where Peter Parker
debuted as Spider-Man so Kingpin now
owns the rights to the Spider-Man
trademark and uses it to sell all the
licensed Spider-Man merchandise it's
pretty genius although I guess it only
really works if your hero has a secret
identity and cannot claim the trademark
themselves okay that was the first five
episodes of She-Hulk now it's time to
give it a grade for legal realism
[Music]
foreign
man I wanted to like there's some funny
jokes if for no other reason than the
line Captain America [ __ ] they did cover
some legal issues that exclusively would
have come up in a superhero world and
dealt with them in a way that is
quasi-realistic that being said the
courtroom scenes are complete nonsense
all of the legal terminology is just
complete word salad so sadly I'm gonna
have to give She-Hulk a c for legal
realism legal inaccuracies make Devin
mad yeah so the bottom line here is that
some of these clients got royally
screwed by their attorney if that sounds
pleasurable to you then check out
today's sponsor wink and check out this
link over here for more legal eagle so
click on this link or I'll see you in
court